they may check it been around the corner
yeah but they take
it and I get honestly I think it's
people may call it dangerous I call it
one of the best places ever to event she
the crime rate is very high there huh
the crime rates is very high it's
probably the worst in stab in it yeah
it's probably the worst in London but I
I'm saying how I get on with Muslims up
is is is very nice and I because I go
there with the intelligence of honesty I
really believe that they're in the
Demonic cult and I want to pull them out
like you believe that about us yeah so I
go there with sincerity when I'm trying
to pull them out of the fire you hav't
answer my question go anyways just make
something clear I come from I have a
family my family they are some of
Christians not my family my my site my
wife's side they're Christians proper
Christians I mean they no Caribbeans
some the proper
Christians to you H why haven't they
done anything to you yeah I'm giving
them da I'm the mom yeah the mom coming
so what I'm saying to you if you look at
the only religion that is standing and
guest this Antichrist uh movement is
Islam you know this all this liberal
liberalism lgbtq how it's been forced
upon people how the only reion I
standing firm and guess is not backing
down is
Islam the reason that they see huge War
Ang Islam because for example the only
religion that stands up up that know
alcoh D true Society weest alcohol weest
sexualizing women we against what
gambling we against we and guess what
they call usury because that destroys
societies even some people can benefit
from it but overall people been
destroyed so they look as Islam would
you like my opinion on what you just one
second I have to finish so they look at
Islam as a as a threat for them and what
is Islam is what Islam is not just for
you to be inide mosque Islam is for the
people and for the Elites for the
government too you understand so as for
Christianity is dying in the Western
World remember who brought Christianity
to Africa and Caribbean are the
Europeans the same people that Force
Christianity upon our forefathers and
our ancestors have left it completely
you understand the only religion they
see is Islam but what is very sad when
you see Christians who believe in God
unit with the atheist with other groups
and against Islam right now the points
all them points you making I think were
absolutely spot on I think Islam like
they like um Christianity should be more
zealous on its f we are but there's not
many real Propet Christians who who
profess to be Christian right so Islam
are zealous against um ex uh
anti-lgbtq love that Lov it they're
against um abortions like all Christians
all Christian should be yeah everything
what you're saying every Christian
should be every Christian should be
against what you're talking about every
Christian and you know that I'm against
I'm totally 100% against all what you
just said there and most every Christian
that I know should be otherwise I
wouldn't be Associated make you think
you should be on that side yeah with
this side hold up come on man who the
winning team it's not going to be a
winning team winning team listen bro no
yeah me was going to say to you look you
went on the monologue though you I
didn't
I yeah go go on go no no problem go why
you catch your name sorry D ask me too D
my CHC yeah point where I'm getting is
this there's going to come a time yeah
there's going to come a time you can't
say remember my words every single one
here there's going to come a
time when the West Rises up against
Islam yeah because Islam if you you look
on the whole come been raised Islam what
are you talking about through the worst
we went through the worst man our B
listen listen Iraq was destroyed because
of fake lies Afghanistan and talk about
the Western it was lies
Russia yeah the Russia now become
problem Russia stay this way you know
for us to be safe no problems why
Christianity not speaking out do you
know what Christianity for example to
make it clear to you to understand where
I'm coming from you have you Christian
preachers here day in out every Sunday
yeah who they attacking Islam but to be
honest not the
Christian no no no Bob Bob paper boy
you're talking about this this is a
small
world small world I'm saying this is
nothing hit me out hit me out this what
I'm saying in the park they don't talk
yeah what is bringing down Christianity
world of Christians have led
Christianity some of it because of this
way of life in the western world that
affect them it's disgusting not all of
it some of it will agree but some of you
is discussing against it here no doubt
about that the point here is that what
you have to understand the Christians
attacking mus Islam in the reality
majority of Christians who left
Christianity because of liberalism not
because of Islam in the
but those guy who left Christianity
either they they end up atheist or they
become what Muslims cuz they see Islam
is a practical religion Christianity is
Not Practical religion okay now can I
believe Jesus died for his season and
sing right listen well I know that Jesus
is God you don't have to get on but
Jesus Is God absolutely but listen
listen to what I'm saying listen listen
to what I'm saying BR listen to what I'm
saying now we believe a real Christian
believes yeah when you're talking about
Antichrist that the far right or
Antichrist the liberal this liberal gay
transgender whatever Madness like Pro
abion
disgusting Abomination yeah right that
is Antichrist yeah so we believe that
the fire rights Antichrist we believe
that's Antichrist but we also believe
that Islam is Antichrist is antich so
listen to what I'm saying this is what
I'm trying to say yeah it is Antichrist
your your Christ is not Christ I don't
know who he is yeah our Christ makes
more sense than your Christ your you you
Christ is a go become a
baby doesn't make S to any human being
see saying name again don't don't what
I'm saying look don't what I'm saying to
you
don't now you missing the point the
reason that Western World left
Christianity because you believe doesn't
make any sense the Muslim world have not
left
Islam now when you come to children in
our time or young people you said you
know God the almighty the greatest the
most powerful become a baby someone
she's happy this doesn't make any sense
man you understand you know it doesn't
make any sense so the they look at Islam
you know what there's only one God who
is a perfect God he's not in need of his
creation self-sufficient it makes sense
so you are the's
cathol this is what you
got D the problem is oh no where is it
like a
manifestation it's a you know what
manifestation me so the enemy will send
these people in and then he gets swamped
don't hit me out me out you have to know
why Christians are living Christianity
why not because it's liberalism to be
honest even if there's no liberalism
Christians if they start thinking deeply
not just deeply in a normal way of
thinking doesn't make any sense God
who's Almighty the greatest all powerful
become a baby someone his
na bre
got beat up do you believe do you
believe there is a devil yes I do do you
believe the devil is corrupting this
whole world yes the devil corrupting
he's corrupting this whole world right
so he's coming out he's poisoning the
minds of the media poisoning the minds
of churches yeah to where you've got
some churches that will marry men for
instance they're going completely
against the Bible you know it's not in
the Bible they going completely against
that's right all right so the ene so the
enemy is poisoning poisoning
corrupting the minds of the unbelievers
that's what the Bible says yeah but the
devil corrupted the most corruption is
you believe in God become baby right
listen so the Bible says the God of this
world yeah meaning the devil has blinded
the minds of the unbelievers yeah so
that they cannot see the illumination of
the glory of Jesus Christ who is the
image of God yeah that's what it says so
you have been blinded Islam has been
blinded and I tell you for why I'm going
to tell you for why I personally this is
my opinion
all right one second this is my my
opinion yeah that when Muhammad was
getting Revelations right you can say
what you want to say and I'll say what I
want not deal with my points no listen
you go off topic listen sure you're
diving into what let me speak I believe
for that 23 years of Revelations that he
was getting from the angel that the
angel was a a fallen demonic Angel okay
and he come up with your Devil's
Doctrine that's what I believe should
Analyze That as a man of thinking should
we analyze that so does watch watch no
wait watch let's Analyze That does a
devil Teach You To Worship a perfect God
who doesn't not become weak and get bit
up by
people does God teach does the devil
teach you you should believe in God who
is perfect no one can overpower him
that's good devil teach you
that I'm ask step by step understand
after that's God teach you to worship
God who is perfect no no no wait wait
step by step step by step
question tell me no no utilize our
intellect that God gave us our sound
reasoning yeah now if someone comes to
me and he said to me worship God who is
perfect there's nothing like unto him
the greatest he's not in need of no one
everyone's in need of him he's one God I
say you know what that's the god I want
to rely on another person come worship
God become a baby someone CH his na be
someone beat him up I said bro I'm more
powerful than you God if someone beat
him up I can beat up that guy
which one is the the the satanic one the
god is perfect he has no beginning no
end he overpower everything all the time
or God become baby someone beat him up
you finish yeah which one answer my
question I'm asking you finish which one
I'm not going to answer I'm not going to
be putting that pen to answer it n no
have to be just you have to be just cuz
people people will
know see
listen aldah break it down
that's why any human being with sound
reason would know Islam is the truth
answer my question I respect answer my
question if someone comes to you say to
you Don worship God who is perfect he
has no beginning or end he power he
overpower everything all the times
remember all God become a baby someone
beat him up which one Jesus has got no
beginning on I'm not asking about Jesus
I'm asking you simply when he came I'm
asking you question
Jesus my question answer my question
Jesus about Jesus you can answer it can
answer itally I Pro to him said wrong
one man sin came into the world you can
answer a
question can a question before you go
ask a question a
question a question question
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway don't answer my question before
you
leave us repeat it let repeat let repeat
the
question anyway I sumarize it my
brothers all right
nextway anyway
Al there was J today J life you know you
know my point to Christians out there to
Christians who are sincerely seek the
truth which one is a satanic teaching
God that is perfect he has no beginning
no end he's all powerful no one beat him
up he's all powerful he will destroy
anything anyone in the blink of an eye
he's the greatest the almighty all the
time or God become a baby someone beat
him up I don't have to say which one
I'll tell you to choose alhamdulillah
for Islam so refuge in Allah before we
the yeah we seek Refuge from Allah with
Allah and against Satan and when you
analyze so what another one I was going
to mention another one which one is
satanic the Quran is been preserved but
the Bible from God has been
corrupted please make that sense for me
Inc in no no God God Almighty he's by
he's book was corrupted we don't know
the writers the language that the Bible
is in is not in the original language we
don't know the translat we don't know
the original scripture for us to verify
but we have the Quran the Quran we are
not in the scripture you go to Africa to
Asia Britain Europe America the Muslims
at the age of N9 and 10 memorize the
Quran word for word and letter for
letter and this been the case since the
time Prophet mammad wasallam that's why
if the Jews and the Christians and the
Muslims all of them decided to burn
their scriptures the only scripture will
remain with us is the Quran we have
memorized it and we can bring it back
into the written form so therefore
according to this m guide him Satan was
more powerful to preserve his scripture
but God is weaker to preserve his
scripture logic dictate rather the Quran
was from God and the Bible lot of it was
from
Satan take this stuff
yeah don't give him my mic yeah you want